when this film began with the young
character watching Dragonball Z on
Toonami and sleeping in a Dragonball Z
comforter that I had when I was 13
[Music]
boyhood is directed by Richard Linklater
and stars
Ethan Hawke Patricia Arquette and mostly
unknown actors and what this film is
about is a young kid growing up
experiencing adolescence and everything
that comes along with it we've seen that
a million times before right
yes we have however this film began
filming in the summer of 2002 with the
young Maine star and filmed yearly all
the way until last year with the same
actors this film was made over the
course of 12 years it's a nearly three
hour film at 2 hours and 46 minutes and
we actually get to see all the actors
including the young boy who started
working on it all the way back in 2002
aged as the film goes on and it's that
filmmaking technique that makes this
film incredibly special at times boyhood
can be a film that as you are watching
it it doesn't feel particularly
important moments don't seem to add to
anything of real weight it's not until
the film ends and you begin to reflect
on it that you realize that the message
of this film is the fact that moments
are just like a string of milestones you
do this you do that and now you're gonna
do this now we're gonna work until we do
that but it's not until the film ends
and you reflect on it the message and
the weight of the film really hits you
at least that was my experience because
as I watch this film I was thinking to
myself this is really well-written these
performances do not feel like
performances they feel very much just in
the moment this dialogue doesn't feel
like a movie dialogue it just feels like
people are talking the real drama of
this film comes from just how real it
feels and the message behind it that
life is just a series of milestones and
once you hit them you just on to the
next one you're on to the next one what
the movie really is is a long series of
short films in fact the director himself
said that was his approach to the movie
he was going to make a whole bunch of
short films over the course of 12 years
to show this boy growing up and it's
really remarkable to actually see like
Patricia Arquette and Ethan Hawke
way back in the early 2000s you're like
wow we're actually going to see these
actors younger in a new movie it's
really different and there really is no
other film like this and that as I said
is the thing about this movie that
really sticks with you and it doesn't
feel like a gimmick either because it
took 12 years there's a lot of work put
behind this and I know that a lot of
people are gonna come out and say this
movie really isn't that special if it
wasn't made over the course of 12 years
well then it would just be some boring
movie where nothing happens and I can
understand how a person would go to this
movie and think that was boring because
nothing really happens it's a lot of
really really interesting conversations
and very very cool filmmaking techniques
it's not really until the film draws to
a close where you realize it's messages
about life are very profound Patricia
Arquette Nathan Hawk in particular are
very good in this movie young actor who
plays the boy in the film you do see his
performance get a little bit better as
he starts very young and then gets older
which makes sense because as an actor he
is maturing and as a person he's
maturing but the idea that I discovered
my love of filmmaking like back in the
early 2000s and this movie just started
filming back then it's crazy to me now
in regards to flaws in the movie it's
very difficult to really pick out one or
two I mean the fact is it's a very long
movie I'm not seeing this movie have
very good replay value unless you really
want to examine it this is not the kind
of movie popping at a party and say hey
guys we're gonna watch this movie for
three hours because it's not that type
of film it is a very intimate film it's
a very small film as I said the young
boy's performance at first was a bit
weak his eyes darted around a lot it
didn't seem like he had much focus but
it improved over time overall boyhood is
a very very different and unique movie
and it should be seen because of this
Richard Linklater once again has
excellent dialogue in his films I loved
his before trilogy that is the best
example in my opinion of a real romance
portrayed on film I'm gonna give boyhood
and a - as if you have seen this film
I'm interested in knowing what you
thought of it are you impressed by this
technique as much as I am because I
can't even imagine the idea of
physically filming a movie for 12 years
it's crazy because all these other
actors and the director has made other
movies during this time period it's nuts
thank you so much as always for watching
guys and if you like this you can click
right
here
[Music]